[Music]
hey you guys happy monday man we still
got to get the lights right in here well
you know i'm done with the house
now that i'm done with that house over
there i'll be able to [ __ ] work in
here and we'll get this light right yeah
because he's been gone like pretty much
all day and yeah you know i've been
doing other things and haven't really
had time to fart around with the lights
so i'm just kind of like whatever good
enough
uh but yeah i'm gonna go back to go get
the ladder i got a i left a ladder down
there i couldn't take it with me because
i had to take a bunch of other [ __ ] but
and it went over there tomorrow get that
ladder and then that's it yeah so uh as
we mentioned previously i i kind of said
before that i'm just gonna stop worrying
about we're still gonna do like matinees
um you know every day like when we see
movies and stuff but i'm not gonna worry
too much about oh we have to do them at
exactly 3 p.m every day because it's
just too
stressful
i mean other things are going on yeah i
mean i guess from now on it won't be so
bad because like i said you'll be home
most of the time so you can you'll be
around at the time but i don't know so i
don't know i just kind of felt like well
we can just jump on whenever yeah
another thing we're we're probably gonna
do this we're gonna have the main show
on wednesday
okay and then we're gonna have side
tracks on friday yeah that way friday is
the pre-game because we can drink
and then when we get out we'll go to the
club
yeah i kind of feel like when you first
said that i was kind of like i mean it
won't really matter too much to people
because you're still getting a stream on
wednesday and friday night just it'll
just be like friday night it'll just be
free-for-all not really a topic which in
a way kind of like might make sense i
think that's better because then that
way friday night i don't have to worry
about we can just have a good time you
know it's the beginning of the weekend
if we want to go out after i don't have
to worry about no um you know getting uh
doing all the topic and [ __ ] like i mean
i still gotta do the research obviously
on a different day but i could do it on
a different day so yeah so that's
another thing we were talking about yeah
and if we got to be somewhere that night
because man we're missing out on fridays
and saturday nights types so if we got
to be somewhere we'll just [ __ ] start
the show a little bit early and then end
it a little bit early yeah that's all
like i said i i get i think i got two
like rigidly into we have to do things
at a specific time but
i don't know i kind of feel like as long
as we do it kind of around the the time
then it'll be okay yeah but you know
no we got bee's nest in the uh
um
he showed me a picture of himself now
that he's been on trd for a while he's
[ __ ] trimming down you trim it down
bees it's not gonna like i said
you you just get in the [ __ ]
first couple months of it you know i
mean it's like it gets a lot better as
it goes um
i will tell you though man
go to planet fitness get some real
weights don't
that little [ __ ] dumb the dumbbells
that you're dealing with it's not enough
you need those machines too that will
help you okay
so um
we saw venom
well i was going to say a couple more
things okay good uh one thing uh shout
out to lady vesuvius our latest patron
uh also another one from the uk so thank
you again we'll we'll thank her again on
the main show but i just wanted to make
sure i mentioned that also um i think
our stream yesterday on no time to die i
think it got cut off at the end yeah um
we weren't like talking about the movie
anymore yeah but one thing that i did
say that i think got cut off was that i
think for the first time in a long time
every single
we saw venom yesterday morning um every
single
preview for the movies was a movie that
i wanted to watch trailers and the
trailers yeah yeah um so i was like i
was actually really excited about it
because every single movie there was a
[ __ ] ton of trailers too but every
single one i was like man that looks
good hey that looks good too and i was
just like wow holy crap like look at all
the good [ __ ] that's coming out yeah i'm
glad we renewed our amc stubs a-list
thing yeah if you uh subscribe to um
what's that what's that [ __ ] one
midnight uh [ __ ] midnight's edge they've
got some hollywood
studio insiders guys that work the
studios
and they uh they kind of
let you know what's going on you know
through their friends
[ __ ] the studios and and the theaters
have
they can't [ __ ] around anymore they got
to get asses in seats
they can't just go around making movies
for directors you know what i mean
producers making whatever movie they
want they're going to have to attract
the crowd so and they he they were
saying
that
the new movies for 2021 will start being
a lot harder hitting
and it looked like they were they were
right
and well and i liked too that they were
kind of like all over the place it's
like you know there were big kind of
tentpole ones that everybody's kind of
looking forward to like dune and stuff
but then there were kind of like weird
ones like you know one night in soho
which i'm really super jazzed about that
trailer looks fantastic that looks like
a really cool movie the the movies we've
been seeing for the past couple years
have been in the works for [ __ ] five
years in some cases yeah
and
they had to play them because they were
making them but evidently they were
considered those were kind of like the
passe movies
from the old strategy they're gonna have
to [ __ ]
be real crowd-pleasing movies now
and uh they're gonna have to [ __ ]
because they got to compete with
streaming services yeah i mean the thing
about it though is that you know
streaming services their overheads are
so much lower yeah that you know they
can obviously make a lot of indie stuff
um you know in series and everything
like that so there's kind of like
something for everybody if you want to
go see like go to a theater and see a
big ass like temple movie you can do
that but you know what i mean they had a
good movie about knights
they were showing that yeah that was
that called the last duel yeah it's like
based on true story that yeah that also
looks good had adam driver and a bunch
of other guys in there and it was all
medieval it looked [ __ ] kind of
realistic like a lot of times it's the
robin hood [ __ ] that looked
realistic they were [ __ ] going to the
duel over this woman
you know she was [ __ ] claiming the
other dude raped her it's based on real
yeah it's based on our real story yeah
so that looks really good
dude looked the dune trailer the new one
looked [ __ ] fantastic i hope it's
going to be good i think it's going to
be good
um just everything that [ __ ] last
night in soho that ghost looks yeah one
night yeah yeah yeah that looks really
cool the the new coming halloween looked
better than the last one halloween kills
yeah yeah that looked pretty that starts
next week i think or the end of this
week yeah and uh that like i said house
of gucci that looks really yeah
gucci liquid
what's his name ridley scott ridley
scott adam drivers and that's driver and
that one too and lady gaga and lady gaga
which i'm impressed with her with her on
on screen her on-screen [ __ ]
performances are really good lady gaga
can act i mean [ __ ] man she was in uh
what do we see the [ __ ] one where his
[ __ ] yeah the the musical thing yeah
that musical one she was great in that
yeah she was actually really really good
um
a star is born the star was born yeah
i gotta think of it a second
when when we saw the venom the first
venom
and that's about two years ago yeah
2018. i thought that was one of the
better movies of the year i loved that
movie i thought it was really cool it
was super fun i thought it was really
good
um i'm not a big superhero movie fan
if it is a super if it if it is a
[ __ ] superhero type movie it's got to
be really entertaining and this is one
of them that i really thought was great
and the other one i thought was great
with shazam
i thought aquaman was pretty good
uh
wasn't too impressed with the wall of
[ __ ] well the thing about the thing
about that's you know all those have in
common is that they're fun they're funny
yeah you know what i mean i mean the
venom movies next year a mixture yeah
yeah are funny yeah and honestly i need
violet yeah honestly i have to say i
really liked the first venom i think i
liked this one better i said away i
think this one was funnier yeah um i
liked the first one it was yeah it was
more violent still pg-13 but they got
away with a lot of [ __ ] um you know they
very artfully like edited things so it's
still like the the violence was implied
but it wasn't like super gory tom hardy
[ __ ] had a hand in writing the story
he also uh partially produced this movie
yeah
so he's he's all in on this you know and
you can tell he's having a [ __ ] blast
playing this character he loves his
character and he loves this [ __ ]
movie i love tom hardy
um yeah he does the voice for venom too
and um
yeah i was impressed man and after
[ __ ] seeing bond
i hope tom hardy's the next james bond
he'd make a great job i think tom hardy
making [ __ ] great james bond he's the
right age he's and he's such a great
actor he's so versatile he's in like
just so many so much uh different [ __ ]
it's gonna be honest you know it's gonna
be [ __ ] hard
to fill [ __ ] daniel craig's shoes i
have a lot of respect for dan and
craig's and and his work in james bond
you're gonna have to be somebody
to fill that
bond void and i think tom hardy can do
it that's just my opinion i'd love to
see him as james bond i would actually
like that as well yeah
but uh but yeah so the thing about this
one i think what i liked about this one
um one i like that they added the woody
harrelson
uh you know serial killer character
uh which what's his [ __ ] name kids uh
carnage well i know carnage but i can't
remember what his real name is cassidy
something yeah yeah and he looks great
in this movie
woody [ __ ] looks a lot younger he
looks [ __ ] like he's in great shape i
mean
you know that they asked him to be in
this because of natural-born killers
right yeah i mean and he's playing and i
love that he's like i said everybody in
this is just they know this is just like
a fun
[ __ ] superhero movie and everybody
like woody harrelson is just like
camping it up
he's just kind of like chewing the
scenery and it's awesome it's great and
i really love too
i think they what they did i think
initially the first venom movie i think
carnage was supposed to be in the first
venom movie but i think everybody
responded so well to the interplay
between eddie brock you know tom hardy's
character and venom like you know being
in the same body like the argument it's
like everybody liked that so much that
they're like okay well when we make the
sequel we're gonna focus on that
and i think that was a good decision
because that shit's hilarious because
think about how that would be having
this like sort of evil
brain eating
symbiote that's sharing a body with you
and it's it's so funny they almost do it
like a [ __ ] up rom-com yeah yeah it's
like but it's like really [ __ ] up and
violent and it's like it's like one of
those
things that's what i'm talking to
[Laughter]
it's talking to me
[Laughter]
that's why i say bizarre [ __ ] i don't
know
you are [ __ ] up i love [ __ ] like he
just like talks to himself all the time
and talks to things yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] big so yeah he's like that same
thing well that's what's so funny about
it i think is that you know eddie brock
has that except it's real and it's an
alien yeah so i really like that that do
you know i was reading the wikipedia
page for this earlier and they actually
toyed with the idea of calling this
venom loveful terrace apart
actually because they have a yeah not
the joy division version but there's
like a cover of it like sort of a
ray-ish kind of version it's got a real
good score it has a lot of cool a lot of
songs in it uh [ __ ] it's got love to
tear us apart it's got uh some rap songs
some of them original rap songs that
were in it in the end credits
they were all pretty good they were all
good
and um i'm not a real big fan of modern
rap but uh this was good i thought this
was really good modern wrap remember
venom yeah yeah i like it yeah i like
that i like that song yeah it was a
bunch of [ __ ] that was good in it it was
uh i just look man i think he knocked it
out of the park it was much better than
i thought it was gonna be and i loved
the first one this one was even better
i think the reason that this was like i
said the because the first one they had
to establish you know venom coming to
earth and like taking over and them you
know him like being compatible with the
symbiote and everything like that
whereas this movie
you know that's already established so
you can like widen the story out you
know what i mean because all of that
stuff has already been set up so now
it's kind of like he's he's had venom in
him for so long that it's almost kind of
like you know they're like an old
married couple at this point where
they're already fighting where they're
always like [ __ ] fighting with each
other and everything and then they have
to and then they like kind of break up
at some point yeah which that's what you
said he's like hey they broke up yeah
they broke up they did break up he broke
up and
venom jumped out of him and it was going
into random people
and
he wasn't real compatible with them
eventually he got into some but he goes
to the goth club there's a lot of goth
influence in this woody harrelson's evil
girlfriend what's your name shriek yeah
yeah she's kind of like this black goth
chick
and um played by naomi harris it was
also money petty in the bond movies yeah
yeah she's seen two movies with her in
two days she did a real great job in it
um
it goes to the [ __ ] goth club and
they're having a damn um
like a costume party yeah it's like a
masquerade yeah and
venom says he's out he's come out of the
[ __ ] closet look at all these weirdos
because he doesn't have to hide himself
he's walking around and and man it's a
great costume because i made it myself
that [ __ ] was so funny myself and he's
looking like the life of the party and
[ __ ]
he could only see me now because he
didn't think that he could survive on
his own without him and that kind of
[ __ ] you know
i'm free i'm out yeah
[Laughter]
it was there is a lot of like
funny [ __ ] kind of like gay jokes in
it about them being together and being a
couple and breaking up and then [ __ ]
and
and in the end he goes i love you well
it's also like in a way it's like yeah
it's a crazy monster movie but it's also
kind of like about self-acceptance
and it's about accepting your partner
with all their flaws yeah it's like it's
so it's kind of sweet in that way right
well that's what's what would happen
it's not a sexual thing it's just that
uh it's a symbiotic creature and it
can't stay inside of somebody that it's
just not compatible with right
and it's compatible with this guy gives
him superpowers and [ __ ] all kinds
and helps him out
and
they fight but
he does love they do love each other
it's [ __ ] funny you know and i love
that that's how it would have to be
because whatever you're doing it knows
yeah it knows everything it was
attracted to his
was telling him no to do you know be
nice and then
he's trying to get him [ __ ] he's
trying to get him to get him back
together trying to get him back together
and [ __ ] [ __ ] funny
can we can i just give a shout out to
mrs chen
the lady that owns the shop where she
where he goes and buys like the
chocolate and stuff like that because
she knows about venom they established
that in the first one and uh she's only
in like a couple scenes
but and at one point like venom like
takes her over like when they broke up
and stuff like that and oh my god i love
mrs chen so much i just i would watch a
whole movie about her she's [ __ ] good
and i like the fact that it addressed
[ __ ] what it would like to have a
[ __ ] alien symbiotic [ __ ] creature
that's just basically [ __ ] has to eat
brains and it's kind of rage filled
it [ __ ] up his apartment he can't keep
an apartment straight it [ __ ] jumps
out and starts [ __ ] cooking [ __ ] and
[ __ ] bringing big plates of food
knocking things over it's messy and [ __ ]
they're fighting each other they got
into a big fight
it there's just a lot of really cool
scenes and
tom hardy [ __ ] he pulled it off man
and i really believed it you could tell
it's all cg well yeah but you're just
buying it hook line and sinker and
and it's it's it's not the special
effects it's the storytelling yeah
um
my hat's off to [ __ ] tom hardy if he
helped write this story
man more we need more of that bro
because no the story story's right there
that is a good story i mean i laughed
out loud like a lot during this movie it
was even funnier yeah the dialogue was
[ __ ] hilarious um it had but you know
what it wasn't a lightweight movie i
mean some of that [ __ ] was straight out
of [ __ ] it was like alien horror and
stuff and a lot of violence
biting people's heads off um you so you
see
when i saw
the first venom and he says i'd like to
bite your head you bite your head off
and watch them roll like turds
i want to see that well you do get to
see that
yeah like i said a lot of the final
carnage doing it yeah because you can't
have venom doing it because you're
supposed to be the good guy yeah he's
supposed to be sort of
so you see carnage doing all kinds of
[ __ ]
and uh you're like oh okay this is what
they're like you know and uh
no spoilers it's even at the end just
wait through the credits and and you're
gonna see that sets up the next movie
and uh it was awesome yeah there's not
there's not an end and credit scene
because we waited but there is a
mid-credit scene well they're tying it
in with
don't don't spoil it don't spoil it okay
don't spoil it well i mean anybody
that's read the comics i know that but i
was just i was like oh they're doing
that yeah okay all right this actually
the story is mostly taken from uh the
storyline which is called maximum
carnage like from the comics um and a
lot of people like why didn't they just
call the movie that i just i don't know
who knows but um yeah so yeah shriek is
in this like that's you know it's just
like in the comics she's uh you know
cassidy's girlfriend uh who has that
sonic sonic scream thing
and uh yeah so
and then you know woody harrelson the
serial killer he gets [ __ ] he gets
his own symbiote
carnage who's like
kind of bigger and stronger and has more
arms and [ __ ] like that so so you have
all that going on while you also have
like eddie and venom like kind of
fighting and breaking up over various
things oh venom eats people in this
movie too but they're bad guys
yeah he eats some bad guys
i mean i'm just kind of crap
that's
i'm just cracking up out
what would you do like he just wants to
eat people yeah you can eat everyone if
you just like yeah
well
i don't i don't want to spoil everything
but [ __ ] venom see when venom sees
carnage she's like oh it's a red one
it's a red one we're gonna die
yeah it's a lot stronger all right yeah
that was [ __ ] funny though yeah yeah
yeah
so
[ __ ] tom hardy's character what's his
name again in the eddie brock eddie yeah
eddie goes uh i promise you
come back you know because he just goes
back inside he's like yeah no he's like
they show this in a trailer so it's not
that much of it
just because come back and i'll let you
eat people
you promised because yes you can eat
something
[Laughter]
yeah because he's like well he has to
like tamp down his uh his worst impulses
yeah that's one of the main things that
they fight about all the time
is that venom really wants to eat
people's brains and obviously eddie
brock does not want him to
so he's always he's kind of trying to
uh keep him on a diet i guess this is
the best way to put that yeah of not
eating human brains but it's just not
good enough yeah he's eating bad people
though
[Laughter]
beezness says watch the squid game
seriously everybody is talking about
that i want that on it's on uh netflix i
think okay i'll have to get her it's uh
korean i think what's it about it's a
korean series
um i'm not sure but it's but every i've
seen every single [ __ ] horror channel
like just okay you know just
just squirting over it um it's a series
i still gotta watch that i still gotta
watch uh the new mike flanagan series
i'm so [ __ ] behind you guys and i
think louis recommended another movie on
netflix called the old ways
and i wanted to watch that as well
because i've also seen that all over the
horror channels and i haven't watched
any reviews like i said i don't watch
reviews of stuff like before i watch it
cause i don't want anything spoiled i
just like to come to things like with a
fresh eye
but so that's another one so i have like
a huge list i might watch that one
tonight because it's just a movie
but
um yeah i definitely want to get into
this quid game because everybody is like
[ __ ] getting erections over that and
uh you know it sounds kind of cool so
we'll see how that goes so far i can
vouch for bond i'm a i'm a [ __ ] bond
fan you got some guys that are [ __ ]
go hammond and hannah well it did
i'm
i'm not old i liked it i really really
liked it some people are being a little
some guys like nerd erotic i love his
channel and everything they get overly
critical on some of these movies all
right
uh [ __ ] no time to die was a solid
bond flick
with craig in it one of the better ones
yeah i was like i was completely uh i
was completely enthralled and
entertained the whole entire time and
they they wrapped up they wrapped up
daniel craig
james bond they didn't leave any loose
ends and i was happy
um and i could stan and i [ __ ]
stabbed by a [ __ ] um
venom
the ven yeah i mean venom is just a big
dumb
fun
action movie with like a lot of really
funny [ __ ] comedy in it like i said
tom hardy is so [ __ ] great i love him
and everything woody harrelson is
[ __ ] great it has some horror tone to
it too yeah but it's just like it's just
super fun yeah and it's like really
really fast-paced i think it's only an
hour and a half long yeah not boring at
all and it just yeah just no wasted
scenes no nothing ever just like went
jump jumped up like right to the thing
and you know big monster fight at the
end like i said shriek was in there
there was like mid credit sequence
pretty good special effects yeah it was
just it's just like a fun [ __ ] movie
i had a really good time with it
woody harrelson was looking great i mean
i don't know how old that guy is i think
he's older he's older than me he was
looking great at it probably yeah yeah
he was in zombieland double tap yeah
he's holding me by five years at least i
think
yeah probably yeah he's just so great in
roles like this like i said he's he was
really doing uh doing the thing from
natural born killers well i think that's
why they wanted him because of you know
being
what's his face mickey yeah natural born
killers and that's kind of like what he
does in this one but
everybody that's in the movie knows that
it's just like a fun silly
monster movie but like with darker
elements yeah and like i said i really
really liked they took it seriously
though they did yeah and i mean honestly
the best thing about it like i said is
the interplay between
uh between eddie brock and venom yeah
liking them just like constantly like
bickering yeah like inside [ __ ] fight
like a married couple i know it's
[ __ ] so funny and it's like everybody
and it's funny because everybody in the
movie like acknowledges that too like
like and his ex-fiance like her new
boyfriend dr dan is just kind of like
they so need coupled counseling yeah
because it's just kind of like the
fights that they have are just like so
[ __ ] funny because that's like
exactly what would happen yeah you might
have some people like some of these
other channels go they'll win this guy
oh come on man if you've ever been in
the army that's what it's like
that's what it's like [ __ ] in the
army living [ __ ] at close quarters
with a bunch of dudes that are your
brothers it's constant [ __ ] bickering
over personal [ __ ] because everybody
lives together yeah literally lives
together [ __ ] sleeps two feet
from you constantly well i mean that's
what happens anybody this is what
happens just yeah what they do
everything about each other whether
you're a married couple or whether
you're best friends or whatever anybody
that lives in close proximity to
everything about them yeah and you know
everything about them even though you'd
rather not sometimes that's just kind of
like how that's how that happens
right and it's just like it's really
funny when that's applied to like a
person and an evil
alien symbiote yeah i mean that's just
very funny to me yeah so i just i don't
know i just really really enjoyed it i
thought it was super fun it was funny
that when they broke up yeah the [ __ ]
alien goes to the club it try and just
be himself and everyone is like yeah
i am out of the eddy
the [ __ ] teeth it's obviously not a
costume but i thought it was great yeah
yeah he gets up on the he gets up on the
stage and it's like a big long speech
like i said it's like it's like a it's a
big dumb fun monster movie but it also
like i said it was kind of sweet
actually because it was kind of talking
about
their friendship their bromance you know
he had a lot of good um
moral messages in it about friendship it
you know his [ __ ] solid
mythological storytelling solid solid
storytelling
they are going to make another one oh
they have to uh tom hardy well tom hardy
even when he did the first one yeah uh
you know that did well so they knew they
were going to make a sequel but he had
signed us
a contract to do three at least so they
are gonna do one more and it looks like
they are gonna do a third one because
this one is um is doing really well like
this one actually like uh you know broke
some records and stuff like that so it's
made like
more money than they expected like over
the first few like over the opening
weekend i put it up there i i put it
i put
well okay
i put [ __ ] venom one up there with
shazam i hope the [ __ ] is that shazam
too
yeah he's gonna have a rock in it is he
gonna be black adder in it i think not
black adder that's a different that's a
whole different show
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know what's it called i
can't remember black adam black adam
yeah yeah black adam black adder was
that yeah that's that british tv show
i think black adam is from the shazam
series right
i think yeah i thought that one they
hinted it like right he's saying he was
going to do it he was getting ready for
that
yeah i thought they were working on the
next shazam yeah right i don't know if
it's like in pre-production or
post-production shazam when shazam
because i i follow follow the rock on um
instagram and like date two or three
of uh
shazam opening i think it was like you
know
he got on there and he goes all right
guys you thank you very much for coming
you know to see shazam we're going to
make another one
and [ __ ] blah blah he's going to be
in it you know and then he said
something about blackadder adam
but uh i haven't checked back with it
because he was some i think the rock was
somehow involved with well he was a
producer i think yeah
he saw the [ __ ] returns and he's like
yeah okay we'll make another one he goes
thank you very much yeah like i said i'm
sure they're making another i don't know
when it's going to come out but
yeah that would be and like i said they
hinted that he was going to be in the
next year yeah some you know some people
didn't like shazam i thought the tone
was perfect because i grew up with
shazam [ __ ] you know scenes i had a
lot of fun with that one that was really
entertaining version of the shazam tv
show
and they did kind of capture it they
they made it better actually you know
the tv shazam went that good but
they just uh captured the kind of fun
of
with 70 superheroes you know what it was
well i mean you can [ __ ] on the modern
day all you want like um you know
superhero movies and stuff but you gotta
say like prior to recent times
nobody took comic books or superheroes
seriously so like every time they made a
movie or a tv show it normally was not
that good no i mean other than like the
first superman and [ __ ] like that that
was obviously really awesome
but i kind of feel like a lot of the
time people are just like oh this is
just like a dumb dumbass
like they didn't really take it all that
seriously you know what i mean and um
and i'm not saying that taking it
seriously like it can't be fun obviously
but i'm just saying take it seriously is
like a piece of
fiction like don't just like make some
half-assed no whatever like [ __ ]
those nerds will watch it you got to
respect the story yeah you got to
respect the story you got to respect
what the original creator was trying to
do i mean look at the crap comic book
movies they made in like the 80s and
stuff like they were just awful most of
them were just awful and even in the 90s
yeah like a lot of the comic book movies
they made back then were just [ __ ] i
mean yeah because you could tell they
were just like stupid cash grabs it was
just kind of like when they
made vid if they made like movies that
were like video game adaptations and
most of them just sucked yeah because
you could tell that they were just oh
all the kids are playing this game so
let's make like some cheap jack movie
out of it and they just they were awful
when i was growing up there were only
three good
superhero movies that was superman one
two and three
and three was
if he had problems yeah
although that was the one with richard
pryor right yeah i feel sorry for him
because richard pryor was a huge fan of
one and two i mean he did not want to be
a comedy he wanted to be [ __ ] serious
yeah and he wanted to be he got in that
movie but he didn't like the script and
they wanted him to try to like kill
superman and because i can't do that man
[ __ ] i love superman don't make me do
that yeah
so
they took it around where richard pryor
actually kind of
helped save superman in the end he was a
bad guy kinda but a good guy in the end
yeah he was good-hearted yeah
yeah no yeah yeah he's a computer guy a
bunch of people are saying like yeah
squid game is awesome and that we need
to watch it
um and everyone's saying yeah midnight
mass that's that's another one that's
the mike flanagan one that's also on my
list god i have so much stuff i gotta
watch you guys
hardy needs to do another mad max yeah
when are they gonna do another mad max
honestly it's funny because we're gonna
get right on one but it it didn't happen
yeah well i mean when we were actually
after we were watching uh after we
watched venom i was kind of like
watching tom hardy and i was like man
this makes me want to watch mad max fury
road for like the 20th time
because i never get sick of that movie i
could just watch it over and over yeah
esther said midnight mass is next on my
watch list
uh does anyone remember tank girl i do i
actually i actually quite liked tank
girl
yeah i thought it was okay i haven't
seen it in a long time yeah i haven't
seen a long time but i remember liking
it when it came out i thought it was
like i thought it was like a lot of fun
but you know i'll i'll watch it again at
some point just to see if it
you know
uh if anyone has peacock tv you'll be
able to stream halloween kills i'll put
i mean like i said we pay for that uh
amc thing we we reinstated
the amc a-list thing
so we'll be able to see it for free
constant mike flanagan made that series
and it has a great writing midnight mass
midnight massacre yeah it's netflix it's
his new one he made haunting of hill
house and
uh and uh haunting a blind manor and he
made movies like oculus and [ __ ] like
that huh he's getting drunk drinking
bohemia beer yeah we're uh this it's
monday but and normally we wouldn't
drink on monday but tom came home from
the house and he's like hey you want a
drink i was like yeah why not
i mean you know so i'm not getting drunk
or anything this is just one but
why not it's it's toward the end of the
day it's a little bit that past five
i'm done with that house so i'm [ __ ]
just relieved that i got done with that
house so early
well i mean
yeah there's nothing more i can do there
that's been like yeah because you've
been over there like pretty much every
day like you took the he we took the
weekend off so we could do some other
[ __ ] but yeah it's kind of like
we couldn't really get a lot of [ __ ]
done here because
he was doing [ __ ] over there like
yesterday we went we went to
finally i went to home depot like i'd i
was concentrating on doing this office
because this was going to be on camera
you know what i mean so i said okay i
want to get this office done like before
we do anything
um so we haven't really done anything in
most of the other rooms like the bedroom
does not even have
curtains
it has a bed yeah and the tv yeah and
that's it
like everything's put up in the closet
and everything like that but it's like
we haven't put up any artwork we have
there's not even a curtain rod so it's
like yesterday we went to home depot and
i said i'm buying a curtain rod
goddammit because we have curtains we
just haven't put them up yet so i buy
this place i was talking to the landlord
and he's going you got to get on that
new don't procrastinate you know he's
like he's like
i'll se you know i'll sell to you you'll
save 20 because there's no realtor
you're just buying it directly from me
we don't need realtor you you don't need
a realtor to find it you'll say
20
and he goes but if somebody comes with
520 000 you know i'll take it so you you
know don't procrastinate you want to get
this thing soon this is uh he's
pressuring me well see that's the thing
yeah our landlords they're lovely people
but they own a bunch of properties
but you know they're getting older and
you can tell that they want to retire
he's 70. they want to retire and they
don't want to manage all these
properties anymore so i think they're
trying to sell them trying to get them
all off yeah and he's uh
77
or 78
so he's pretty old
you know but he's moving around good he
doesn't seem to be that old but he you
know so he's saying you know he had
trouble with the stairs here but like i
said that's why like it took them like a
really long time like to get up in the
notes yeah that's why they moved out of
here because that's why they moved into
our world they were here they were
living here
yeah okay
or they were they were living in this
house or they were living in another one
that was two-story yeah they were living
in another two-story oh okay i thought
they were they weren't living oh no
that's right because yeah there was
somebody else here renting this i can't
remember what their name was but i got
some of their mail the other day
but yes they were live in another
two-story house but this was enough they
owned like 12 or 13 properties something
like that yeah
so like kind of all over this area but
let's hope i can get a loan this big
see he's like you can do it yeah you can
do it it's not gonna be a problem it's
not gonna be a problem but they probably
say that to everybody well that's what
i'm saying yeah we'll see how it turns
out when it turns out i contacted vfw
and my representative there man [ __ ]
and i got him on it
he's gonna uh i'm in line as soon as
when he gets back to me i'm gonna i told
him what i wanted
and uh i'm gonna have him go go to the
va for me because you got vfw behind you
then they they know exactly who in the
va system to go to what test to get it
on to get it as quickly as possible and
to get you your [ __ ] you know what i
mean
so
i mean you should be able to get yeah
something at least like i said because
you get all kind of like benefits like
you know you should be able to i got
[ __ ] i haven't even asked for that's
what i mean
it's like you know for all kinds of you
get your you know your pension every
month but you don't really ask for
anything other than you have your
housing allowance i could get food
allowance that's what i mean
all you ever all you ever use is you
know your pension and your medical like
you go every six months or whatever
like for a checkup and you go for your
eye doctor that's like all you use if i
was greedy and [ __ ]
i could sit i could sit around and
[ __ ]
lodge all kinds of [ __ ] requests for
[ __ ] and say yeah i need [ __ ] anger
management i need this and that and they
send you to these programs they pay you
to go
that's what i mean it's like you should
take advantage of sometimes you're gone
for a couple weeks though it's not here
they gotta fly you out to somewhere else
and then you're in the hotel with a
bunch of other [ __ ] veterans and [ __ ]
[ __ ] getting into trouble and [ __ ]
those dudes riding that system to make
money they getting paid you're getting
paid
well i mean the va system i would take
it i would take it if i if i had that
available they got guys that work
they got guys that work the va system
full time like it's a job
yeah well like i said i don't believe
them yeah [ __ ] man you did your time
yeah [ __ ] take advantage like i said
that's there's a lot of people that
don't have access to that so you
probably should yeah yeah and grampur's
hammer said pension and medical is huge
yeah like most people don't get that
so you know i'm not going to get a
pension that's for sure
no man i'm in nine i don't have i
haven't had medical insurance for years
i'm at 90 percent of active duty pay and
i get raises yeah full medical yeah
so
you're like good it's mostly just if
you're yeah but it's better than like
what i have which is zilch yeah
which is don't get sick or
or pay thousands of dollars
it's like yeah it's like you know oh my
hand fell off well i can live without
that i guess
i have another one i don't see conan
dude he needs to be up there well this
is jenny's studio now [ __ ] um
kodian's probably going in the gym
which is that which is next door yeah i
got a gym and then i got another room in
there it's gonna might be my like studio
it's gonna be tom's mankey yeah and uh
the top probably go we'll go in there
and uh if i ever want to do one of my
own streams i'll do it in there so it'll
be in the background so he'll have his
own office i'll have it that's why i
can't believe how many [ __ ] rooms are
in this house
when they first like um showed us this
house
and we looked like downstairs is like
gorgeous but when i came upstairs i'm
like [ __ ] this is like a whole house by
itself
downstairs doesn't seem to be that big
because it includes if there was a
kitchen up here yeah you could just live
up here and never go downstairs ever
downstairs doesn't seem to be that big
because
it's got like it's broken up in kind of
a weird way and it's and then the it's
the garage it's the garage garage
there's a laundry room yeah there there
is a bedroom down there but uh
i mean up here here's a lot better there
are what four bedrooms and a big huge
like kind of sort of like quasi open
yeah like a living area and it's massive
right and see i'm kind of like hesitant
to invest a bunch of money and furniture
and [ __ ] paint and [ __ ]
for something that [ __ ] i don't own
yet
well if you can get the loan then yeah
soon
goes through then i'll start [ __ ]
working on it you know we'll worry about
it i can help you out with it but like i
said my credit is not fantastic it's
probably better than i want to claim you
as just income as a renter
oh now see that might work out better
right so you won't even be involved in
because like i said i mean my credit
sucks but it's not
terrible but i did have a foreclosure
but that was like 10 years ago
so i think i'm gone now so i think after
a time that they don't really like that
was during the great collapse
yeah that was like because my mortgage
was underwater that happened to
everybody yeah
yeah and i was just and the house wasn't
even that expensive to start with and i
was just kind of like
yeah i think it was eighty thousand yeah
eighty four thousand something like that
so yeah and i'm just gonna and actually
i have six times that and i had moved
out my ex-husband was still living there
yeah but then he abandoned it
and then i was just kind of like well
i'm not paying for the [ __ ] because i
don't live there anymore i had moved out
i'd moved to an apartment over here so
you know that's how that whole [ __ ]
worked out but yeah well i don't know
we'll see how it goes all right uh you
done talking i'm done
you done we already finished a drink but
yeah seriously
uh the venom movie is super funny worth
seeing i honestly like i liked it better
than the first one and i liked the first
i liked the first one too yeah but this
one was like a lot more fun yeah i
thought it was like funnier
you know i liked the serial killer and
the whole angle and the whole carnage
thing and
sam's gonna have to [ __ ] make sure
that it's as good as this
shazam too
that's all i'm saying
i'm excited to see shazam too we'll see
yeah it's probably it'll probably come
out next year
next year or
the year after but like i said
i'm actually kind of jazzed because all
the trailers that i saw i was like every
single one of them was like that's a
movie i want to see
yeah which isn't something that usually
happens but
i think every single one of them was a
movie i wanted to see
so we'll probably be doing a lot of them
we're going to go to the theater we're
paying for the [ __ ] i hope dune doesn't
let me down
well don't get your expectations up too
it looks awesome
i thought i thought james bond was going
to suck
i was [ __ ] pleasantly just surprised
when i when that movie when i watched
that movie it was like oh this is this
is actually good this is good i didn't
like i didn't think it was going to suck
but i was just kind of like well i'm not
going into it with any like xp i was
like this will probably be fine
um
i didn't really have any expectations
but
it i was actually pleasantly surprised
yeah i mean i've found it really really
enjoyable and really entertaining
um you know and like i said even though
it's almost three hours it totally did
not seem that long it went by fast it
totally did not happen i was one of the
better ones in the series i was totally
involved i thought it was one of the
better ones in the series
oracle says one thing i like about what
i've heard about dune is that they cast
a good type for duncan idaho
yeah
that was the guy same guy that they
played that was the same guy that played
aquaman wouldn't it
yeah that yeah that looked like jason
momoa didn't it
oh yeah somebody said where's grogu he's
still in the living room isn't he yeah
we put groggo up here oh my god he has
to come back in here yeah like i said
we've been like moving stuff around
there's like a bunch of stuff in the
living room
that was still like boxes in there like
i said we're so [ __ ]
we're so behind we're trying to get [ __ ]
done but there's still like crap all
over why don't you pick up the camera
and show them the whole room
here do it
i made a video earlier
oops well
i made a video earlier
okay just rotate it i know but okay
so
that's
do
i haven't got like all the um posters up
yet because i don't have enough frames
yeah and the lighting is not correct
really
yeah look at my fabulous curtains i love
this okay
look look at that gothy [ __ ] over there
oh there's my hairline
yeah
see
yeah
but yeah i'm just
this is like so
i have so much crap in this room
had everything like set up so i didn't
have to like move anything but you know
okay there we go there we go
but yeah
i'm just
we'll see oops what happened
oh [ __ ] i touched my phone what did i do
okay nothing okay
oh i turned on bluetooth tethering i
didn't need to do that but it doesn't
matter as long as i have usb tethering
on we're fine because
as long as my phone's like attached
yeah hugo said it looks awesome lots of
space i can't believe
i didn't realize how much bigger
this room was
uh
versus the other one until i put all my
[ __ ] furniture and set up all my
desks in here i'm like oh my god this
room is [ __ ] matter there's three
desks in here and a bunch of computers
and then there's like yeah i have two
yeah two different room there's a
bookshelf over there there's a bookshelf
over there there's a bookshelf over
there i got [ __ ] everywhere in this
place yeah and we're on we're on the
second floor
yeah and it's like i got a whole i got a
little dressing room right there a
little coffee station i got my own
coffee pot yeah i can go over this just
like a [ __ ] office it's awesome
all right so are we ready to
wrap it up all right so tonight
we'll probably like i said i either
watch the old ways or i might start
watching like one of the series i'll see
how long like it takes to watch them so
we'll have something to like talk about
tomorrow
but yeah go see venom let there be
carnage it's super fun
um you know
we'll uh see what happens tomorrow might
we might be on at three tomorrow because
you're not you don't have to like go to
the old house right oh i mean you have
to go briefly but
you don't have to be there all day right
all right so maybe we'll actually be at
three o'clock tomorrow like usual and
then wednesday night do you want to do
the show on wednesday night
like the topic do you know what that you
know what the topic is
how to survive a catastrophe okay all
right yeah i'm ready for that everybody
voted for that because they were like
yeah tom's gonna be super fun on that
show yep
[Laughter]
and i was like yeah i agree somebody
like uh recommended that a while back
and i was like yeah that sounds like a
good so we'll we'll do that on wednesday
night maybe and then friday night we'll
do sidetracks yeah because then i don't
have to worry about
we can just have a good time and drink
and talk about a bunch of i want to go
for a ride tomorrow [ __ ]
yeah you should yeah
you should i cuz i'm [ __ ] been
[ __ ] wound up man
yeah well you know it's been a very
stressful
couple of weeks i need to go for a
[ __ ] ride but tear some [ __ ] up maybe
go down that biker bar during the day do
some day drinking
we were coming back from when i was in
there man i was day drinking with their
bikers i'm going to get that [ __ ] on
video for you
the biker bars right across the street
from the [ __ ] mexican market what
i've been telling you about i used to go
down and get the el yo katano that's a
cool place i went in there and ate and
dude the [ __ ] they improved the menu
a lot
a lot better went in there and got like
three gorgitas
and they were with uh with uh carnie el
pastor pork el pastor
and um they were good man real good had
like these corn muffins and sliced had
beans and
and [ __ ] uh carniel pastor with it
and uh i think it had mayonnaise which i
didn't expect that but it had mayonnaise
and [ __ ] lettuce with gotta think
guacamole came in and down
stone urn
[ __ ] good man that's good
um i'm gonna have to go eat there again
we we ate there before but that was like
that was a long time ago yeah that's
much better now they have all kinds of
stuff on there man mexican chicken
that's a cool place like i said it's
like half like a mexican grocery store
type thing and then half a restaurant
yeah and it's not a fancy restaurant
it's like a little diner and then all
the work guys
when i was in there man all the workers
were coming in
and uh
they were supplying the workers with big
old [ __ ] buckets of soup
mmm mexican soup they were giving them
soup they were giving them all tortillas
and [ __ ]
sending them to work so you know in the
morning i guess they have a contract or
something they must spend five or six
work crews stop by
to pick up their breakfast it's either
breakfast or lunch probably both because
like i said around this area there's
like farms it's all farms so there's
like a lot of like farm workers and
stuff like that so it's like they're all
because they all go to the circle k by
our house too getting the breakfast
sandwiches yeah that are two for four
dollars yeah i'll make a video in there
i make a video in there sometime i'll
con i'll show you the menu
and they give you a min's got two sides
to it yeah you should go you should go
like uh tape that they had all kinds of
stuff on there they didn't have they
didn't have machete though they didn't
have machete yeah they didn't have that
but the
cooking seemed to be pretty good yeah
it's really it's funny because he used
to like ride his motorcycle there from
our old house and that was like a while
but now we live like right we live right
here it's like not around the corner but
it's not that far about three miles it's
about three miles from here
it's like funny when you talked about
day drinking
and i was thinking about when we were
coming back from home depot or lowe's or
whatever it is yesterday
and there was like some dude in front of
us that was just weaving all over the
place and it was like four o'clock in
the afternoon right yeah or five o'clock
in the afternoon i'm like ooh somebody's
day drinking
out here in the country i was like [ __ ]
it yeah
it wasn't tortilla soup
i don't think it was tortilla soup it
was just a big old bucket it's a soup
and then had some other stuff wrapped up
that they took with them
and then they had uh
uh
a big old stack of tortillas about that
high wrapped up in the lunar foil that
they sent out with it
they had the whole thing and took they
took it away in a big old basket that's
what they were giving i don't i don't
know what i didn't know what was in the
other stuff but some of it was some of
it was soup they were taking a huge
ladle and filling up that damn bucket
man yeah i love soup of all kinds it's
just some kind of
some kind of broth type soup i might
have to write it i had vegetables in it
i think it might have had noodles in it
i went and i just went to publix deli
and got a tuna salad damage today yeah a
little bit of a salad so you know all
right so we'll be back tomorrow
talking about a movie or a series or
whatever we decide to watch later on
this evening
uh so thanks everybody for dropping by
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow